-Sadie, you're an actor
and part of your craft is making
all kinds of sounds
and, you know, for the things...
-Sure.
-...so I thought it'd be fun
for us to make some sounds
right now.
It is time
for the Mimic Challenge.
Here we go.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-♪ Mimic Challenge ♪
♪ Mimic, mimic ♪
♪ Challenge, yeah ♪
-Now, how it works is we're
going to take turns
making noises
with different objects, okay?
And the other person has
to immediately match
that sound
as precisely as they can.
Sound okay? Don't look.
Are you ready?
I will make
the first noise for you.
Here we go. Ready?
-Oh.
-Okay.
Sadie, make --
make this sound.
I don't know if I can do this.
-Mm-hmm.
[ Laughter ]
-Can I do this?
Pbbbbbbbt!
[ Laughter ]
-Khhhhhhh!
-Wow! That's not bad.
[ Cheering and applause ]
[ Ding ]
[ Rimshot ]
That's pretty good.
-Yeah.
-Alright, now,
this is my turn to mimic.
-Okay.
-This is this.
-Oh.
Alright, Jimmy.
-Mm-hmm.
-Make this sound
[ Mooing ]
[ Laughter ]
One more time?
-It's a lot longer
than you'd think.
[ Mooing ]
[ Laughter ]
Hurrrrrrrrrrrrr!
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Yeah.
That's like on pitch.
[ Rimshot ]
-Not bad. On pitch?
-Yeah.
Look at you.
-Alright.
[ Chuckles ]
Sadie...
-Oh. No. [ Laughs ]
Make this sound.
[ Chipmunk squeaking ]
[ Laughter ]
-Whah whah whah whah whah whah
whah whah whah whah.
[ Cheering and applause ]
[ Rimshot ]
It's kind of --
You know, it sounds like a cat.
I was ready for that.
-Oh? Good, yeah.
-Yeah, mm-hmm.
-That was perfect
and also on pitch.
Alright, this one.
Alright, let me see
if I can get this one.
-Oh.
-Hm.
Okay.
[ Honk ]
[ Laughter ]
-Okay.
[ Honk honk ]
Alright.
Give it to me one more time.
[ Honk ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Braying ]
Huahhh!
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Rimshot ]
-Yes! Yes.
[ Ding ]
-[ Brays ] Huahh! It's, like,
a little breathy.
-Hunnh! That was great.
-It was a little breathy.
-Okay.
-Alright. Alright.
How about this?
This is a text message.
-Oh.
[ Cellphone bloops ]
-Oooh-errr!
Oooh-errr!
-[ Laughs ]
[ Bell dings ]
-Oooh-errr!
-Alright. Is this -- This is --
-Oh. I have -- Okay.
-Spreading butter on toast?
-Oh. Alright, Jimmy.
Make this sound.
Maybe it will catch -- Yeah.
[ Butter knife scraping ]
[ Light laughter ]
[ Scraping echoes ]
-No, I'm sorry.
-That's cheating.
-I'm sorry. No, no, no.
You can't do that.
You want more?
-Yeah, I want to hear it.
-You want more?
[ Butter knife scraping ]
-Khhrrrr! Khhrrrr! Khhrrrr!
-Oh. Oh, yes.
[ Bell dings ]
Yes.
[ Applause ]
-Was is it too --
-Very nice.
-Was it so realistic?
-It was so good.
-[ Laughs ]
-Whoa! Whoa!
-Oh, my gosh.
I am so embarrassed.
Okay.
-Great. Two minutes.
This is the --
-Take the toast.
Thank you very much.
Yes, I got the toast.
This is the last round here.
This one is for you.
Here we go.
[ Netflix tone plays ]
-♪ Da-dunnnn ♪
-♪ Whaaaaa ♪
[ Bell dings ]
-That's it right there!
That's how the pros do it!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Sadie Sink!
[ Cheers and applause continue ]
"The Whale" is in theaters now.
We'll be right back
with a performance from Dayglow.
Stick around.
[ Cheers and applause ]